u.s president joe biden says the united
states would defend taiwan against an
attack from china these comments come
amid rising tensions between the two
regional neighbors and mark a departure
from washington's long-held ambiguous
stance china has launched a record
number of incursions into taiwan's air
defense zone in recent weeks beijing
claims the breakaway territory as its
own
dw correspondent william yang joins us
now in taipei william how have the
president's remarks been received there
in taiwan
the taiwanese government has actually
come out and reiterated that
it's actually uh well try its best to be
determined and uh defend itself uh at
all costs which i i think once again uh
highlights uh what the taiwanese
government has repeatedly been saying is
that the responsibility of defending the
island in the end will rest with the
taiwanese people and the taiwanese
military and the taiwanese government uh
i think another thing that is very
interesting and uh that needs to be
noted is that the white house actually
came out to uh walk back uh what biden
said during that town hall meeting uh at
cnn uh which they said that the us has
not changed its policy on taiwan this is
actually the second time uh that biden
has actually created some confusion with
his uh like comments on policies towards
taiwan uh over the last few weeks
beijing has been stirring tensions with
taiwan recently entering into the
territories air defense zone over and
over again
why now
this uh so-called gray zone tactics uh
set by a lot of the experts have
actually been used by china since 2020
and they have been sending a lot of
fighter jets and military aircraft into
taiwan's air defense identification zone
uh over the last year but uh the
increased number basically followed the
national day celebration in china and
also the national day celebration in
taiwan and that has traditionally been a
very uh sensitive period of time where
china will always try to uh prop up its
military activities or its
threatening tactics against taiwan as a
proof or as a
way to show both the chinese people in
china that they are still very
determined to reunite with taiwan but at
the same time to warn taiwan and also
its allies in the region that china has
not given up the choices of using
military as a possible way to reunite
with taiwan if possible
have we
seen any response from beijing to these
mixed messages coming out of washington
so far uh we have not really uh got any
official responses uh from beijing
because actually current usually uh
china will make official responses
adiron actually this time when they have
the daily uh
foreign ministry briefing so maybe we
will probably hear something from
beijing when uh questions were being
asked but another possibility is
probably yet again that beijing might uh
send another wave of fighter jets as
they have always done as an
some kind of response that they're going
to make to show both washington and
taipei again that the possibility and
the rising tension will be there and is
always going to be there
were washington to officially change its
stance on the topic would that embolden
taiwan to push for formal independence
from
china i think under the current
government and the president that is not
going to happen because the current
president has been very clear that she
prefers uh the status quo which means
that not trying to uh directly provoke
beijing but at the same time not trying
to uh think that uh relying on the us
and uh all the uh recent activities that
we have actually seen in the region uh
will be enough to actually secure
taiwan's independence i think of the
question of independence is such a flash
point that uh currently no ally and no
one actually even inside taiwan is going
to be publicly and openly supporting
that idea because they know the
consequences that might come with that
decision or such an announcement
is going to be very unpredictable and it
could actually lead to a series of very
very uh like complicated responses and
the situation across the taiwan street
dw correspondent william yang and taipei
thank you very much
thank you